The new "Frasier" series on Paramount+ brings
lots of new faces into Dr. Crane's life, including
a young mom with a tragic backstory named
Eve.
But where may you have seen the actress who
plays her before?
The 2023 "Frasier" revival shares a name with
its predecessor, but its setting and timeframe
set the new show apart in plenty of key ways
from the classic '90s sitcom.
The most important addition is Frasier Crane's
adult son Freddy.
Frasier uproots himself to visit and eventually
live with his son in Boston at the series'
start, giving the revival an environment entirely
distinct from the iconic Seattle setting of
the original series.
At the start of the first episode, Freddy
lives in an apartment with a friend of his
named Eve.
Frasier initially assumes that Freddy and
Eve are in a relationship before learning
that Eve and her infant son moved in with
Freddy after the child's father — a firefighting
colleague of Freddy's — died on the job.
"I don't need to be told who you are!"
"I wish I could say the same!"
Jess Salgueiro plays Eve in the "Frasier"
revival.
Her filmography before joining "Frasier" consists
largely of television work, including roles
in shows from the past decade that span a
variety of genres.
"Workin' Moms" aired on the CBC in Salgueiro's
home country of Canada between 2017 and 2023.
Netflix carries the show for international
viewers.
As the title implies, it follows a group of
mothers attempting to overcome the myriad
struggles of balancing an active career with
motherhood in an urban Toronto setting.
Dani Kind's Anne Carlson is one of these moms.
In Season 1, Anne decides that her daughter,
Alice, might benefit from some discipline
and hires a young woman with a stern demeanor,
played by Salgueiro, to babysit.
The character takes on the nickname "Mean
Nanny…"
"'Mean Nanny'?"
"Yeah, that's what we call you.
'Mean Nanny.'"
"I don't care.
I kinda like it."
…but she and Alice end up getting along,
undermining Anne's plan.
Mean Nanny continues working for Anne and
becomes a recurring character through Seasons
2 and 3.
Her storyline reaches its dramatic apex when
Anne's best friend Kate finds out that her
husband Nathan is having an affair with Mean
Nanny near the end of Season 2.
This affair, understandably, leads to Mean
Nanny's departure from the series.
Salgueiro plays the character in a total of
12 episodes.
Canadian sitcom "Letterkenny" takes place
in the fictional Canadian small town of the
title.
Frequently causing drama in the town of Letterkenny
are its hockey teams, including both the Letterkenny
Shamrocks and the Letterkenny Irish.
Three of the show's core cast members, Reilly,
Jonesy, and Shoresy, play for both of these
teams at various points in the show.
Season 5 introduces a women's hockey team
called the Letterkenny Shamrockettes.
Throughout that team's periodic appearances,
its two key players are Betty-Anne, played
by Kelly McCormack, and Mary-Anne, played
by Salgueiro.
In a May 2020 interview with Popternative,
Salgueiro said that she and McCormack had
such a good time on the "Letterkenny" set
that she left sore one day as a result of
nearly laughing during filming.
Referring to "chirping," the show's term for
ribbing or mocking, she said,
"I remember leaving set one day, I think probably
our first time we ever did it, which was this
locker room scene where Betty-Anne and I are
chirping each other out.
We left that day and I'm like, man I have
the worst chest pains.
And I was like, what is this?
Oh, it's holding in laughter.
It's literally from me trying so hard not
to laugh."
"Who would have thought the girl who ingested
mosquito eggs after drinking out of mud puddles
would almost be accepted to community college?"
In the first episode of the satirical superhero
show "The Boys," protagonist Hughie Campbell's
partner Robin Ward, played by Salgueiro, dies
after Flash parody A-Train collides with her
at a high speed, killing her instantly.
After her death, Robin retains a presence
in a few more episodes in Season 1.
Hughie is so upset by her death that he joins
Billy Butcher as a member of the Boys organization,
which is devoted to stopping the world's overpowered
and egotistical superheroes.
While he's still coming to terms with losing
her, Hughie is haunted by visions of Robin,
particularly after starting up a new relationship
with Starlight.
Before long, though, Starlight helps him move
on.
Salgueiro shared some insight into her brief
but impactful time working on "The Boys" in
a September 2019 interview with Collider.
"I had a Spidey sense when I was reading these
scripts — I hadn't felt that way about anything
I'd read."
"The Expanse" aired on SYFY for three seasons
before its cancellation and subsequent return
as an Amazon original series.
In the first Prime Video season of "The Expanse,"
Salgueiro debuted as Chandra Wei, who has
an amorous entanglement with Amos Burton.
Complicating their interactions is her devotion
to her boss, Adolphus Murtry, who she credits
with saving her life.
Chandra is relatively kindhearted, but Murtry
is outright evil.
So, while Salgueiro maintains a central role
throughout Season 4 as a member of its main
cast, her character's association with the
villainous Murtry culminates with Amos having
to kill her, concluding her run on the series.
Salgueiro told The Fearless Nomad in July
2022,
"I loved playing Chandra Wei on 'The Expanse.
I love the complexity with which she was written.
When something is written well I find that
the character sticks with me and is sometimes
incorporated into who I am.
She's one of those."
In 2020, Netflix adapted the novel "Tiny Pretty
Things" into an original TV series, the first
and only season of which hit the streaming
service in December of that year.
It's mostly set at The Archer School of Ballet
in Chicago, which trains elite dancers but
hides some insidious secrets.
Salgueiro plays Isabel, a former soldier working
as a Chicago cop.
She's tasked with investigating the case of
Cassie Shore, a top dancer whose fall from
the school roof is ruled an accident, but
which Isabel suspects was the result of foul
play.
Salgueiro said of Isabel in a May 2021 interview,
"She had a hard go of it for sure.
She was a dark character."
She also mentioned that she filmed a brief
role in the Netflix superhero drama "Jupiter's
Legacy" at the same time.
Between then and the "Frasier" reboot, Salgueiro
also worked on shows including "Y: The Last
Man" and "Sip," and did voice work for the
2021 video game "Far Cry 6."